We are going to be covering the Day of
the Dead, Dia Deos Muertos.
Um, and we have a friend and someone who
has um plenty of experience dealing with
it as it is his culture is Alex Cast.
Um, so welcome him if you will and he
will go ahead and get us ready to go.
Um, plus go to his website or his
website, his YouTube channel, Just Be
Blessed. Check it out if you haven't
seen it before. Um, but let's start with
this from the top.
Okay. Yeah.
All right. Well, thanks so much for
inviting me to you guys YouTube channel
and Candy Truth. So, that's great. Well,
tonight we're going to be talking about
uh a very a very crazy topic that every
year we it comes right and I know we you
know it's Halloween you know it was
yesterday but now is the tomorrow is
going to be the day of the death
in Mexico and a lot of you know lots of
different uh Latin American you know
countries we celebrate that especially
in Mexico but um believe I don't know
I'm from South Mexico So,
I remember when I uh I took my wife the
first time going to Mexico and she told
me he said, "I thought you going to take
me to Cancun. This is real Mexico
because this is this is this is South."
You know what I'm saying? Like the
culture and all the stuff and
uh indigenous and we're so proud where
we come from and the culture and you
know, things like that. But growing as a
as as a Christian kid, you know, in the
family, Christian family with, you know,
uh, learning the ten commandments, the
Bibles, the word of God, and and I used
to go to the public school and they they
practice the day of the dead. And my dad
used to tell me, "Hey, uh, don't eat the
food is is offered the to the to the
idols, to the the the to the people
dead, you know,
and because they they do I don't know if
you want to go to the next slide. I
don't see the slide.
Oh, yeah.
So, this is where
the slide.
You're from Chiapas.
Yes, I'm from Chiapas. And the next
slide, you can see some uh
Oh, yeah.
uh uh candles and stuff like that. So,
in the evening uh you know, they they
celebrate, you know, they put this um uh
in the cemetery. You know, it's not like
it's a festival, you know. I don't think
so. This is a a ritual there. I mean,
and the people's houses, they have a
they have a
uh they call it like, you know, bringing
the offerings to the dead people, to the
loved ones, what they eat, you know,
what they the favorite uh food or drink
or stuff like that. and and and the the
tradition said that you know I mean said
the spirit of your loved ones you know
the dead people they they come in the
middle of the night 2 in the morning and
stuff like that and they eat the
favorite you know meal stuff like that
so that's the that's the traditional you
know of course you know that's what they
think uh so my dad was always say you
don't be careful you know you don't
don't need that candy don't eat the the
the the bread you the the sugar bread uh
like the you know they make it very nice
different colors. So
yeah,
uh because it's offering to the to the
to the dead people, you know, like we
don't we don't do that kind of stuff,
right?
But I grew up like kind of, you know,
seeing this, you know, and I don't
participate. And of course, you know,
your your friends is like why why you
don't participate, you know, because
I do I don't do that kind of stuff, you
know? I mean, I didn't know what to
answer, right? But the thing is that uh
when I was like, you know, maybe like of
my my mom and didn't let me to go hang
out with my with my friends to go
outside and ask for candy,
you know, and because we ask candy, too.
I mean, you know, and they give you
orange, they're going to give you candy,
they give you money, they give you
different things.
Um,
but uh and the cemetery, the cemetery is
open 24 hours. And let me tell you,
every day normal hours, they close at
700 p.m. 8:00 p.m.
Like the sun goes down, I mean, they
that thing is closed. But for those
holidays, you know, like the like
tonight
is big party. I mean, they go mariachi,
they go music and tamales, you know,
it's like big party, you know,
and of course, you know, it's kind of
like, you know, that's kind of fun, you
know. I mean, it's not anything wrong
with it.
But the thing, you know, it's the idea
of I'm going to offer to my dead to the
to my loved ones that they're dead food
and all the stuff. But let me tell you,
I mean, as a Christian, you know, we
believe that, you know, the word of God
and we need to uh is the lie of the
world. You know what I'm saying? Like
God give you give you the truth. You
know, you don't need to be,
you know, mess around with the dead
because we know what happened when you
die. You know, when we die, you know, we
go
Yeah.
six feet under to go sleep to wait for
the resurrection when Jesus going to
come for the second time. You know, the
second resurrection has power,
right?
Right.
Um I'm saying like a second
resurrection. I mean because Jesus died.
I mean
I mean first resurrection has power but
the second one doesn't has power. You
know that's what I'm trying to say.
Right. Right.
Uh so we waiting for that resurrection.
That's what I'm saying. And but the
traditional here is fun and this and the
your soul is coming. So if we don't
understand and we don't have the
knowledge of what happened when we die,
we are going to be deceived. And this
kind of practice and tradition uh of you
know and this is national. I mean, can
you imagine? It's not just a little
party
down the street, you know? I mean, this
is
like who you are, you know, as a as a
Mexican, you know, and and
uh I don't know if you want to go to the
next I don't know if you It's a little
candy, a little bread.
Yes. Okay, got that.
Yeah. And the next one they has some
they call altars
that they people they build up.
Not everybody does that. I mean Mormon,
the Catholic
um uh beliefs, they do that kind of
stuff
and and they put the you know candles,
bread, the food, you know, flowers and
all stuff. The question is do you think
I mean I mean the question is do you
think is is anything wrong to bring
flowers
to your loved ones to the cemetery?
Uh
h it's a good question.
Yeah. Uh I mean as a Christian you know
I mean as a Christian you say okay I
mean I know where is my you know my
grandma I mean on you know saying like I
don't know I mean we we grew up with
that tradition that you know if you put
flowers and something like that
but we know it's not there. I mean, it's
it's just like I I I think that it's
just like
a memorial, you know, kind of like a
memorial day. I mean, it's something
like, you know, a respect
like, okay, here, you know, maybe I
thought like, oh yeah, I miss my
grandma, you know, great memories and
stuff like that. I'm going to sweep over
here, you know, just to hang out here
with the family. Yeah, great memories,
you know, moments with my grandma, you
know, when we pray, you know, maybe when
Jesus gonna come, you know,
you know, I don't think there's anything
wrong. a different route is that you're
going to be start talking to your
grandma, you know, like you need to be
be careful with that, you know, where
where is the
where you taking that route, you know,
uh but also uh uh the next slide, you're
going to see the it's a huge prayer uh
the the people walk in the street and we
we as a Mexicans we we the saint uh we
celebrate the saint death. Oh,
or the holy death, you know, whatever
you want to call it, uh, translate it.
And it's a big thing. And sometimes we
said this and in in Mexico, I mean,
Mexicans make LA, uh, laugh to the
death, you know, like we ready anytime
you take me, you know, kind of like that
mentality.
Wow,
that's incredible. I've never heard
that, but
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, uh, so
it's kind of like a like a
Like I said, it's tradition. It's not
something like fear. You know what I'm
saying? We don't a little fear like, you
know, dead out, you know? Of course, it
has some, but let me tell you, that's
during the day,
you know, everything's nice,
traditional, you know, outfits, you
know, stuff like that. But the evening,
that's a different story. Go to the next
slide, please. Mhm.
And now they have the idols of the
worship,
[Music]
the the statues of the saint death and
they have a special me uh mass and all
the witchcraft.
You know what I'm saying? It's coming
and
you know all all the mix stuff, you
know, and of course, you know, we
painted our faces, you know, the whole
thing.
But go to the next slide. So it's you
know it looks nice and everything
traditional but it's another thing the
enemy
they give us the deception
and that's the dark part.
The dark part
for sure.
So to me uh go ahead. Oh, sorry. I just
wanted to interject that the last
picture we saw even of the man holding
the spirit of death, I guess, um with a
scepter in his hand or we would call it
um kind of the grim reaper
um
staff to kill people with.
That's what we know of as the Grim
Reaper. So, if that resonates for people
um that's also a god, usually um Saturn
and Kronos. coming to kill people. So
there's that connection you can
continue.
Yeah. But like I said um uh the question
is you know if you go to the next slide
I just want to make emphasis the
celebration of the day of the dead you
know it's a celebration it's a tradition
that help us you know to remember uh all
our loved ones with color celebration
aromas joy and flavor because it's food
and all stuff
it sounds good right sounds good like
you know it's a day to to you know to to
remember your loved ones and stuff like
kind of like Memorial Day like I was
saying earlier,
right?
But the thing is that the thing is that
I don't gonna be
I don't got to be uh celebrating this
and thinking like how the traditional
part they think the spirit of my grandma
is going to show up because my grandma's
dead. I'm not gonna be talking to that.
I'm not gonna be a huge celebration. Oh
yeah, you know, grandma's over there the
picture with the candle and all stuff.
No, I'm not doing that.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
That's exactly what you're saying. I
think is the differentiation between
like you're saying putting flowers on a
grave that's just kind of like I I'm
remembering you versus worshiping
ancestors and their death and praying to
them is starting to conjure them up with
the demon's help to speak to them.
Yeah. And that's the thing when you
start maybe talking and it is very
common and I'm sure you guys heard this
before uh like you know it's been uh
five years I you know for example like
oh my husband die.
Mhm.
He said do you miss him? No I I talk to
him you know very often you know when I
when I cook and and I'm like
that's the deceive part. You know what
I'm saying? Like
when you start mess around oh it's only
traditional. sell me a little candy, you
know, and I didn't I didn't stop eating
those kind of candy, you know. Of course
not. But let me tell you, my mom always
it was like you're not going hang out
with those kids, you know, when I was
10, 11.
But when I was like more like another
like 12, you know, and I told my dad,
"Come on, I really want to, you know, go
because my friends, he was like, hey,
come on, let's go." And my my dad has uh
always taught me, you know, like you
need you need to be nationalist, you
know, like you need to know, you need to
be proud where you come from and the
holidays. What does that mean? And you
know, all those beautiful things, right?
He allowed me to go hang out with my
friends.
[Music]
I bet you saw a lot of things.
Okay. And yes, so I saw like, wow, you
know, fun and colors and food and and
you know what I'm saying? All the
painting and everything. I was like,
this is so cool. And my mommy was not
very happy.
And guess what?
The next year I was there.
You went I'm like,
"Yes, now I'm 13."
Wow.
But now it's not going to be asking for
candy. Now it's a little party with my
friends over there. And now you're 14
and you're like, "Oh, now who cares
about candy?" Now it's a party. And now
you're 15, 16. And you know what I'm
saying? Like
Yeah.
So it takes only only one time. And I'm
sure you guys know
it takes for anything. You know what I'm
saying? Like it takes anything
just one time and you're going to be
hooked.
Very true. So
and let me tell you in a Mexican
you can see all this beautiful tradition
right beautiful tradition and thinking
the colors and days and all stuff but
let me tell you
beautiful tradition but
I am first Christian
the Mexican
that's a hard thing that I said this but
in my heart because I believe that Jesus
Jesus died for me in the cross and I
need to honor him because let me tell
you the Bible the next slide in Psalms
115 verse1 17 says the dead praise not
the Lord
neither any that go down into silence no
so no even the people that die for us
they don't have any praise they don't
praise the Lord anything absolutely
nothing
and the next slide says in Ecclesiastics
chapter 9 56 sake says, "For the living
know that they will die, but the dead
know nothing, and they have no more
reward, for the memory of them is
forgotten, and their love, their hatred,
and their ephne um have now perished."
And let me tell you, I mean, just to see
all those Bible verses, I mean, that's
heavy. I mean, how you going to be
contradict? I mean, I don't I don't
serve I don't serve a God is dead. And
Catholicism,
they preach that kind of stuff. They
don't preach as Jesus that he
is alive right now is he's interested in
for sense. No, that's Mary,
right?
That's what they say.
Yeah. Mary is the one that you need to
be praying for. You know, she is in
intercess
intercessory. you're send with God, with
the God the Father and all this stuff,
but let me tell you the next page uh the
next slide said in Deuteronomy 1891.
It's a little long, but let me tell you,
the Bible is so clear that when you come
into the land which the Lord your God is
giving you, you shall not learn to
follow the abominations to those
nations. I mean, he said like, you know
what, you to the canon to the beautiful
city. I'm I'm going to give it to you,
Israel. Do not learn all those
practices. It's abomination
to the Lord. Okay. There shall not be
found amount anyone who makes his son
and his daddy pass through the the fire.
I mean, can you imagine? I mean, you you
guys did a wonderful job.
Oh, you did the old three hours or some,
you know, investigation about the pagans
and all stuff.
I mean, seriously.
I mean, you can just read the Old
Testament. I mean, of course, how
Israel, the Israelites people, I mean,
the God's people, they were just say,
"Hey, I'm going to do everything what
you're going to, you know, you're going
to be, you tell us."
But no, they were worship by different
gods. And guess what? All the burning
sacrifice, witchcraft, and, you know,
medium and spells and everything, they
came to the to the holies of holies.
Like, how can I get that? I mean, poor
uh the prophet Isaiah.
Oh, yeah.
Seeing all these burning kids and I
mean, that was crazy stuff.
And the Bible contin to say
uh who practice witchcraft uh and all
those interpreted omens and sorcers or
one who conquers spells and medium and
spirits and who calls upon the dead.
They are abomination to the Lord. And
the next page says Luke 20:38.
It says, "For he is not a god of dead,
but of the living, for all live into
him." So as a Christian, we are children
of what? Of the light, of the morning.
We're not children of darkness and the
night.
So we need to be be careful. We need to
be careful that not listen and those
kind of tradition even though they we
are we are from that kind of country
that oh everybody's doing it
right
oh sounds good oh come on it's a little
bite no that food specifically is for
offering to the to and I'm not eating
that
right
there's anything wrong with the food no
anything wrong I mean my grand you know
like somebody made it they when you
offer it's kind of like when you do have
a um the communion service I mean it's
the bread I mean somebody made it in the
kitchen right
but when it's like okay this we pray and
this is to offer to the Lord
that's a special blessing right there
yeah and I mean all of us come from
somewhere and so our culture usually has
traditions attached to it and holidays
um but quite honestly look you said it
really well
um your first and foremost a Christian.
And usually God calls you to let go of
your culture. You become the culture of
heaven first and foremost.
And
according to his word, that means no
human traditions.
That's right.
Um and that's Mark I think 6 and 8. And
then it's repeated again in the Bible
elsewhere.
So
human traditions are just something I
hate to say that I'm you know you we all
have to take it to heart and it's not
easy but
what you're saying even about being
proud of where you come from
is something that
and wearing that as a badge and and
celebrating these holidays along with it
is truly
not the kind of mindset God wanted us to
have. We have to lay all that aside to
go to heaven and actually put him before
everything else.
Yeah, that's totally uh I believe it's
in uh Acts chapter 5. I mean I don't
know exactly but it's Acts it says we
worship you know God first than men.
Yes.
Right. And if men or Caesar or whatever,
you know, government or something that
is telling you something against what
the Bible says,
even the government, you know what I'm
saying? Even my own nation or what I'm
from and all stuff or I mean, no, I
mean, God is first,
right?
You know,
Even your spouse. I mean, exactly. I
mean,
your spouse. I mean, you know, let's go,
you know. So, uh, it is I know it's it's
hard because I've been there and it's
like, no, it's part of me.
Yeah.
Right. Because when I was not in the
church, I mean, this is like like a this
is proud. This is this is this is who I
am and all the stuff. But I just want to
encourage you guys when you start
reading the word of God, you're going to
be free.
Free with no condemnation.
And and the devil wants to the devil
wants us to be in in the state of uh
like
uh how do you say that? Uh
deceive but also but like like like with
no true how do you say like more like
deception.
Deception. And I want to say this word
but like to be dumb. You know what I'm
saying? Like you don't know the truth.
Like
Yeah.
Like just like oh I think it's fine. Oh,
worship this idol. It's fine. Like no,
like no.
Ignorant.
Ignorant. There we go. That's a good
word because let me tell you, the Bible
said in John 14:6, go to the next slide,
please.
And it says, I mean, this is Jesus
Christ, okay? I am the way.
It's not, you know what I'm saying? It's
not way, it's a way.
H E. English is my second language. So,
th is the article like the I mean, he's
the man, you know, he's the the one.
Mhm.
Like it's not anywhere, you know. So
this is so I am the way, the truth,
okay, and the life.
So no man cometh into the father that
believe me.
I mean this is strong words. I mean like
nope. Sorry you didn't you didn't check
the list man. I mean he's the only man
you know Jesus Christ.
Yeah. So
sorry just to interject real quick. Even
Jesus didn't attend the synagogue as a
place to go to school. He was taught by
his mother at her knee.
He though he was Jewish and he learned
some of how to live according to the
scriptures, he actually did not
completely adhere to the Jewish
traditions and cultures either. And so
his example alone is there and he why
would he be trying to call the rabbis
and the Pharisees on certain things that
they were not right on all the time,
you know?
Yeah. Yeah. Uh and I I feel I feel, you
know, sometimes you're going to be
saying like, "Okay, but now you're going
to celebrate. What are you going to be
celebrating?"
Well, you know what I'm saying? Like,
what are you going to be doing? No,
you're going to celebrate life,
right?
Gonna be you guys celebrating Jesus died
for you.
Yeah. Think about your loved ones like
memorial like Memorial Day. You know
what I'm saying? Like Yeah. Yeah, I
remember my grandma. I remember this. Go
to the cemetery. Go go go sweep and I
mean flowers. Think about your grandma
and stuff like that. But don't start
talking to them.
Yeah.
No, no, no. I mean, let's be careful
with that. You know what I'm saying?
Right.
And we need to have respect. That's what
I'm trying to say. I mean, respect. I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that.
Respect.
Be careful, you guys.
Yeah. Because let me tell you when you
open the little window just like oh I'm
going to talk about maybe
somebody's going to be appearing let me
tell that's not grandma
right
that's not grandma
not at all
my grandma
yeah so uh I hope whoever uh is going to
be helping this this my testimony you
know so to speak you know about what I
was convicted what the Lord was taught
me there you know what the word of God
it was truth and also
I mean just to say those are strong
words to say hey I'm a Christian
first then being a Mexican
that's very strong words what I'm saying
but it is truth and I'm stand for truth
I will stand up the flag
of truth first
and um u god bless you guys whoever is
watching this
yeah thank you so much for sharing that
Um, I of course I've done research on it
myself too, but not usually with the
culture.
Um,
have you ever looked into like the
connections between bail worship and the
day of the dead?
Uh, yes. I have more um more slides
about the connection of Egypt and the
gods of uh in Mexico.
Yeah. So
I would love to have those included.
But
yeah, maybe another time, right?
Oh, yes. Yes.
Next year,
definitely.
Yes, because I did my research, too.
Yes. Yeah, we don't want to do that
without the the resources to show. So,
thank you guys for tuning in. Thank you,
Alex, for going over this information
with us.
I hope you guys all are having a great
Friday getting ready for the Sabbath and
we will see you next time on Candid
Truth.
Bye-bye.